Laura said because you're MVP of that
card making history being the first
woman who absolutely deserves it you
guys know I don't around with this
new woke thing where you know everyone's
the same but with Laura senko man woman
alien doesn't purple black white Korean
doesn't matter she is damn good as an
analyst Laura sanco would be your
analyst whether it was 1970 or 2023
that's how good she is at her job Dana
White's Contender series which is called
Laura senko's Contender series because
she's the star of that she's been doing
it for a hot second just these newbies
like this chick this chick is really
good shout out to senko for doing the
damn thing